most of our patients and our staff were
really skeptical about doing a reality
TV show because they've been watching
Jersey Shore and the Kardashians and
they're like whoa you know that's not us
why are you doing this Steve why are you
doing this Andrew oh my god I have a
very close personal relationships with
the cannabis plant
[Music]
for me cannabis it was love at first
sight
I knew intuitively it was an evil plan
it felt good that felt right I've been
very active in the cannabis report
movement is one of these lucky people
who finds out at a young age what it is
that's important to them I'm an agent of
change who's working to bring the truth
about the cannabis plant to the rest of
the world
[Music]
we were approached by about 10 different
producers who wanted to do some type of
reality show and we turned down every
single one of them because it was
evident to me that they had some type of
agenda they either wanted to create
artificial conflict or they just wanted
to show really sensational images they
weren't truly interested in our story
until we met braverman productions and
the Discovery Channel we created
Harborside as a model and so the idea of
being able to present our work to every
American was really exciting California
legalized the medical use of cannabis in
1996 ten years later I opened Harborside
Health Center the state law allows
patients with a doctor's recommendation
to purchase and possess cannabis we have
over 94 thousand registered patients
which makes us the largest legal
retailer in cannabis on the entire
planet we were able to establish a level
of trust that allowed them to be
embedded with us not just at our
facility but in our lives every detail
of our personal lives are is revealed
because we wanted to show who we are not
just what we do because there's a lot of
stigmas about medical cannabis patients
that we don't work hard that we're a
bunch of stoners that we're lazy that
you know we're really criminals or drug
traffickers and all that's a lie that's
been perpetrated by the feds and the
media and this is our chance and our
patients and our staffs chance to shine
they told us that he hasn't drove a
Syndrome intervation arm is the most
extreme catastrophic epilepsy author
they say
Hertz
nothing seems to work
he's about to have a seizure he's
twitching right now come on Jade I'm
look at that look at that look at that
[__] Madonna [__] Matata yeah I know
Jayden come on come on come on Jaden
come on come on
I've heard those other kids with
epilepsy that tried medical cannabis and
they're doing much better
that's why I want to try it I see so we
have the moment how does it fit so it's
not like THC what so I'm correct I'd
love to try that done I appreciate that
I can tell and you thank you very much
thank you for your time
when President Obama was on the campaign
trail he promised not to use federal law
enforcement resources to circumvent
state medical cannabis laws and shortly
after taking office made that official
Department of Justice policy
unfortunately in the past year they have
reversed that policy and they are now
going to try and close down places like
harbor site California law says that
there's a medical reason that people use
marijuana federal law says that
marijuana is illegal at all times for
all purposes that's the conflict federal
law as any first-year law student knows
is supreme over state law anybody that
owns a commercial marijuana store in
California could be the subject of a
federal search warrant at any moment
what we are doing is risky what we are
doing is dangerous it could put me and
my family
and a lot of peril but I believe in it
what we have seen in the past year is a
multi-agency coordinated assault by the
federal government on medical cannabis
it's taken a number of different forms
both civil actions and criminal actions
so we see the IRS is now on a nationwide
campaign of aggressive audits against
medical cannabis providers they are
applying a tax rule to medical cannabis
dispensaries that is not applied to any
other organizations or businesses the
Treasury Department has been contacting
banks nationwide and forcing them to
close the bank accounts of medical
cannabis organizations the Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms Bureau has
contacted every gun dealer in America
and instructed them not to serve medical
cannabis patients and of course we've
seen threats and raids by US Attorney's
not just in California but also in
Montana and Washington state just in the
past few weeks me and my brother talked
about this all the time this
multi-agency coordinated approach it
makes us feel like we're terrorists or
something or we're criminals or no one
else is treated this way and all we're
doing is trying to relieve the suffering
of sick people out there
and yet we can't even get a bank account
and it's dangerous when people have to
use cash to do all the transactions they
can get robbed they can get kidnapped
all kinds of terrible things can happen
to them that's why we don't have cash
based economy in this country there's a
reason for I mean we're placed in this
kind of impossible position where on the
one hand the IRS comes to us and they
want complete financial records as do
our regulators in the City of Oakland
and on the other hand we have the
Treasury Department going around and
getting our bank accounts closed making
it virtually impossible for us to
compile the financial records which the
IRS and our regulators are demanding so
this is clearly not an effort to tax us
or to regulate us this is an effort to
tax us out of existence to force us to
close our doors we are really furious
and feel betrayed by the Obama
administration's reversal of policy on
this issue myself my brother all of our
friends all of our patients not only did
we vote for the president but we also
contributed heavily to his campaign and
I can tell you that his reversal of
policy is costing him millions of votes
not only that the Democrats are creating
an opening for conservative Republicans
we are ready to support anyone who
supports our issue we are single issue
voters unfortunately because when you're
faced with federal prison for what you
do with the living that's what you
become you become a single-issue voter
so we are ready for any candidate
national state and local to support and
to give contributions to if they stand
by us you know we're not gonna vote for
somebody who thinks that we're criminals
that's just not going to happen we're
really pleased now that half of the
Republican presidential candidates have
endorsed our position on medical
cannabis which is allow the states to
make their own laws on this on this
subject
you
[Music]